Former President Trump says
his 2024 campaign
is going to be focused on the future.
But there are some grievances.
He can't just quit
They're going to restore
election integrity.
We have to
and you go to New York
nobody ever gets prosecuted.
I'm the only one they go
after I sending people
that are killers murderers.
They're sending rapists
and they're sending, frankly, terrorists.
We have a woke military
that can't fight or win
and the wind
turbines are all made in China.
They said he's not doing rallies.
He's not campaigning.
Maybe he's lost that step.
We are more angry now
and I'm more committed
now than I ever was.
That was not from Trump's
first campaign or his second one.
That was from last weekend.
Several of his allies are telling me
that they're worried he's
stuck in the past
and are concerned
about the viability of his third run.
Their message to him
has been to move forward,
toned down his messages,
stick to the teleprompter
and those speeches.
But I'm told he's pushing
back on that advice, arguing
that he believes
his message is strong enough
and that
he doesn't think any Republicans
should actually challenge him
for the nomination.
Right now,
he is having a hard time
convincing some people
to join his campaign, a source says.
At least three people have been offered
jobs on the 2020 Ford Trump campaign,
but turned them down, suggesting
maybe they'll join later on.
No one knows more about these dynamics
than CNN's three insiders,
former Illinois Republican
Congressman Adam Kinzinger,
Alyssa Farah,
who served in the Trump White House,
and, of course, Congressman
Mondaire Jones from here in New York.
You saw the message.
He said, I'm angrier than ever.
Is that
is that the start to the 2024
Trump campaign
you think
like it was a funny
quote is not totally scary.
You don't want your elected officials
to be running on a message of
I am angry
and not angry over righteous things
you know poverty homelessness
whatever it might be but angry
because of his own personal grievances
that he didn't win the election in 2020.
This has been a bad launch
from the start for Trump
and why do you think so.
Low energy
I mean we all watched the launch that day
and it didn't come with a lot of fanfare.
It took him
over two months
to even do a campaign event.
He can't pull the rally events.
You've covered many of them.
I've been to many of them.
He can't pull the audience.
He once did.
But point of caution, he's
still polling the highest.
And so long as he has that.
30% on lock.
I don't see how anyone can beat him.
What do you think
of how he's returned
to the campaign trail so far?
Because it has been kind of a slow start.
These were his first
really formal events of this year.
Well, he's tired.
He's put on stage.
I think he is.
He's running the same script.
There's going to be teleprompter Trump
and then there's off teleprompter Trump.
Teleprompter Trump
may talk a little bit about the future.
Off teleprompter, Trump
will be all about the past.
And I think one of the areas,
you know,
as Alyssa said with this, I'm angry
and all this negativity
that works sometimes in an election.
It doesn't work
all the time in an election.
And it's time,
I think, as a Republican
to say leaders have to start
actually putting some optimism out there
when you hear him talk down the U.S.
military.
Look, I disagree with some of the stuff
that happens in the U.S.
military.
As a military member,
you know,
we spend half our times
doing computer based training
and not actually training to fight.
But we have the best
military in the world.
We can defeat any enemy.
And to listen to the former president
talk it down
and say we can't defeat enemies anymore.
I mean, that's
that's like worse than than
the old, you know, malaise in America
kind of thing.
Yeah, but he is still the front runner
as of now.
No one else has even declared
that they're running, though.
It's only a matter of time.
But I wonder with this kind of a message,
is this something that, you know,
with Biden
on the cusp of announcing
that he's
going to run for reelection, that
this is going to be a concern for him?
Is he worried about anything?
I think
if you're a Joe Biden
and you're
the White House, you're happy
to see this president once again
engage in grievance politics
that say more about him as a person.
His character defects
than they do about the people
and the institutions
that he's criticizing.
When is he going to make
the affirmative case
for why he should get a second term
in the White House?
And by that person, I mean Donald Trump.
Of course, he's not doing that.
I don't think he's capable of doing that.
I mean,
it turns out a lot of the stuff
he wants to do
is not particularly popular
to begin with.
And so he's
going to keep trying to divide,
divide, divide.
But I don't think it's
going to go anywhere
because he's no different
from the guy that voters rejected
back in 20. 20.
Yeah, we'll see.
That's
kind of
what his allies have been saying,
Don, that you need to change
your message.
But I'm curious
what you think of what Senator
Lindsey Graham said last night,
because he was asked
about the possibility
of other Republicans getting in the race.
He said he's still betting on Trump
to all these people who are
very talented,
I don't think you could do what he could,
what he did.
And I want him to have another shot
unfinished business.
We need to get ready
for a real spirited contest.
Now, why Trump?
Now, you mentioned like DeSantis,
if you try to tell me
that Ron
DeSantis is not a good governor
in Florida,
I'm not going to listen to you.
If you try to tell me Mike
Pompeo is not qualified to be president,
I'm not going to listen to you
because I think he is.
I am for Trump
not because of the flaws of anybody else.
I'm for Donald Trump
because I know what I'm going to get.
Oh, Lindsey,
I know what I'm going to get.
Does he mean insurrection?
And trying to overthrow
American democracy?
It's.
Listen,
there are some core supporters of his
who are always going to be with him.
But I do think
there's going to be a contest How big?
It is unclear.
There are
people are going
to put their names in the ring.
Listen, if you run as Trump Lite,
this is my concern with Tsatsu.
Obviously, polls
the closest to Trump
is he kind of
takes up all the oxygen in the room.
You have to have a clearly defined lane.
This is where some of the governors
were toying with running.
And Asa Hutchinson,
a young guy in a Sununu,
I think have a more clear path.
They have their own record
and their own vision to run on.
But again,
I caution against the giant field
that we saw in 2016
that just cleared the way
for Donald Trump.
Yes, I'm about Lindsey
Graham, by the way.
So I ran with Lindsey
Lindsey and I used to be kind of
in the same mindset on foreign policy
and things like that.
Kind of,
you know, the John McCain way
of looking at the world
where he has gone now.
I just completely don't understand.
He knows far better than anybody
what January six was.
He knows what Donald Trump
isn't capable of,
which is true leadership.
And for me,
it's just so disappointing every day
to watch somebody
who was frankly talented.
Let me go, Lindsey
Graham was able to really bring people
that would be considered independents,
maybe some soft Democrats.
And he's just gone all in.
I don't know his why here?
Probably just to survive South Carolina.
I mean, look, he is a
he wants to stay in Senate
the rest of his life.
There's nothing
inherently wrong with that.
But the only way to do that
is to make it
through a primary in South Carolina
and when the Trump thing
goes out of vogue in the party
and it will
maybe as soon, maybe it's later,
he'll go back to being what he needs
to be to be reelected.
It's a sad
commentary, frankly, on politics.
Yeah.
There was this moment that I know
I talked to all to the White House.
It caught their attention
is something that Senator Elizabeth
Warren said she was doing
a radio interview
and she was asked
about about Biden running again.
And she was asked about Vice
President Harris specifically
and whether or not
she belongs on the 20, 24 ticket.
This is her answer.
But should Joe
Biden run again for president to be 86
by the time the second term is over.
Yes he should run again
if he's that old in a second term.
The Vice presidency becomes
even more important
Kamala Harris
his choice the second time around.
You know I really want to defer to
what makes Biden comfortable on his team
I've known Kamala for a long time.
I like Kamala.
I knew her back when she was
when she was attorney
general and I was still teaching
and we worked on the housing
crisis together.
So we go way back.
But they need they have to be a team.
And my sense is they are
I don't mean that by suggesting I
think they're in problems.
That's how the White House took it.
She later put out a statement
saying she didn't mean to intend
or imply that
she doesn't think they're a great team.
But that was kind of a moment
that wasn't as emphatic of endorsement
as people suspected it might be.
You know,
I think people are reading
too much into it.
I think she intended
to do what she said initially,
which was defer to the president
I don't think that there is any reason
that she or anyone else would believe
that the president
would not run
with his vice president
for a second term.
And there are concerns within the party.
I mean, that's that's that's obvious.
But what I think, you know, people
wonder about, you know, her popularity.
But the fact is
she won on the ticket back in 2020.
If anything, they have more to run on in
order to be able to,
you know, survive a challenge
by Donald Trump
or I think
many of the other people
like Ron DeSantis who are thinking
about running on the Republican side.
And I think you'll see that happen.
Does she help or hurt
Biden on the ticket?
I think she helps
with certain demographics
and then she's,
you know, hurtful with respect
to other demographics.
But ultimately, it's
the top of the ticket ticket
that matters,
especially when she's clearly qualified,
unlike a
Sarah Palin who I think was a reason
why many people
voted against John McCain.
Fascinating times.
Wonder Jones,
Adam Kinzinger, Alyssa Farah
Griffin, thank you
all three for joining us.